As we wrap things up here, I want to
leave you with some final tips for
how to be successful in this program.
Number one, stick to your schedule.
Working regularly on your courses and
projects will help you learn effectively
and reach your goals sooner.
Number two,
as one of our first graduates said,
be relentless in searching for
an answer on your own.
The struggle and
search is where you learn the most.
If you come across a term you don't get,
spend time reading up on it.
Using resources outside Udacity
to supplement your learning and
become a more independent
learner is really important.
You'll do research like reading
documentation every single
day on the job.
So you want to make sure that
you feel comfortable doing that
from the start here.
Number three,
be an active member of your community.
Another one of our early
grads gives this advice.
Help other students.
This will actually make your
understanding more solid too.
And of course,
when you're stuck, take advantage
of the resources available to you.
By doing all of these things,
you'll build up your expertise and
your portfolio, and
you'll demonstrate that you have
tremendous drive and work ethic.
We're so glad to have you with us, and
we're excited to see where you
go with what you learn here.